GOOD MORNING, THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER AS
MEMBERS KNOW THIS IS VERY SHORT
HEARING SO UH, REALLY PLEASED.
WE HAVE SO MANY MEMBERS HERE. I
THINK WE HAVE A QUORUM TO PLEASE
THOSE MEMBERS THAT OFFICERS ARE
LISTENING. PLEASE COME ON DOWN.
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE MEMBERS
ARE AWARE THAT SENATOR NILO WILL
BE REPLACING SENATOR OCHOA BOGUE
FOR TODAY'S HEARING. WELCOME
SENATOR BEFORE WE BEGIN, LET'S
ESTABLISH ACCORDANCE. SECRETARY
POLICE CALL THE ROLL. HEAR HEAR
WILK PRESIDENT PRESIDENT
ALVARADO. GIL ALVARADO GIL HERE.
ARCHULETTA ARCHULETTA HERE.
ASHBY ASHBY HERE. BRADFORD
POLICE. HER. JONES JONES HERE
WHEN HERE? OH, HERE, PADILLA
PORTANTINO. FROM HERE.
PORTANTINO HERE. ROTH HERE. ROSS
HERE, RUBIO. SEYARTO QUORUM.
THIS IS SEEMS TO BE A FIRST
DURING MY 10 YEARS AS CHAIRMAN
OF GEO COMMITTEE THAT THE WE
HAVE A QUORUM RIGHT OFF THE BAT,
SO I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
TURNING A NEW LEAF DURING THIS
NEW LEGISLATIVE SESSION. IT'S
BECAUSE OF YOUR SUBSTITUTE
MEMBER. THERE YOU GO. THERE YOU
GO. SO WE'RE GONNA, UH START. WE
HAVE A NOW THAT WE HAVE A
QUORUM. THERE'S A IS THERE A
MOTION ON OUR CONSENT CALENDAR,
WHICH INCLUDES FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE SP 536 MOTION, ARCHULETTA.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DODD. ALRIGHT, I WILK. WILK AYE,
ALVARADO. GIL ALVARADO VILLE I
ARCHULETTA ARCHULETTA. AYE,
ASHBY ASHBY I BRADFORD GLASER
JONES JONES. I WIN. HERE. AND
HIGH WHEN I MILO ALRIGHT, SO I
PADILLA PORTANTINO. WARRANTY NÓI
ROTH ROTH, I RUBIO. SEYARTO.
OKAY, THAT ABOUT 10 VOTES. WE'LL
PLACE THAT ON CALL. WE'LL MOVE
ON TO OUR ONLY OTHER BILL ON THE
FILE TODAY. ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
782. SENATOR LIMÓN GOOD MORNING
AND FEEL FREE TO BEGIN. THANK
YOU. COLLEAGUES SP 782 IS BACK
AGAIN. IT REQUIRES THE OFFICE OF
THE GOVERNOR TO MAINTAIN ON ITS
WEBSITE. A LIST OF ALL STATE
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS,
INCLUDING THE PURPOSE MEMBERSHIP
LIST AND INFORMATION WHERE THEY
CONVENE. THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
AN ANNUAL REPORT WITH AGGREGATE
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION OF
INDIVIDUALS APPOINTED TO THE
STATES, BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS.
YOU'VE ALL SEEN THIS BILL BEFORE
IS IT'S THE FOURTH ATTEMPT TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS GOAL THAT WE'VE
ALL GENERALLY AGREED ON. I HAVE
REINTRODUCED THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT'S ESSENTIAL TO GATHER FACTS
TO HELP US INSTITUTIONALIZED
BEST PRACTICES AND GAINS AND THE
GAINS MADE TO DIVERSIFY THE
STATE'S BOARDS AND COMMISSION
WITHOUT DATA TO GUIDE US THE
APPOINTMENT PROCESS. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO SEE GRAB GAPS IN
GEOGRAPHIC, GENDER, ETH ETHNIC,
ETHNIC AND VETERAN
REPRESENTATION, AMONG OTHERS. SB
72 PROVIDES THE MISSING
MECHANISM TO MEASURE THIS
COMMITMENT AND TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE THE GAINS MADE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. UM WE'LL NOW
MOVE ON TO ANY LEAD. WITNESSES
COME UP TO THE MIC, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING. UM HELLO.
CHAIR MEMBERS. MY NAME IS MARIA
MORALES. AND I'M THE POLITICAL,
UM, POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
ESPIONAGE ORGANIZER. POLITICAL
EQUALITY HOPE HOPE IS A PROUD
SPONSOR OF SB 782. FOR THE PAST
THREE YEARS. HOPE HAS PARTNERED
WITH SENATOR ANY MOON ON THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE TO ADVANCE
TRANSPARENCY IN OUR COMMUNITY
REAL APPOINTMENTS. THIS INCLUDES
SPONSORING SB 702 FROM LAST
YEAR, WHICH YOU ALL SUPPORTED IN
THIS COMMITTEE. EACH TIME WE
HAVE WORKED ON THIS BILL OR
EFFORT HAS MET WITH RESISTANCE
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION COSTS SO
THAT THEY ARE ALREADY DOING THIS
WORK AND CITING THE RELIABILITY
OF SELF ATTESTED DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA. IN LIGHT OF THE LATEST
VETO OF THIS EFFORT, HOPE
INITIATED A THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE DATA FROM
JANUARY 1ST TO DECEMBER 1520 23
TO UNCOVER THE TRUE STATE OF
DIVERSITY IN CALIFORNIA'S
GUBERNATORIAL APPOINTMENTS. AND
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT WHITE
CALIFORNIANS HELD THE PLURALITY
OF APPOINTMENTS AT 52% WITH
LATINOS, BLACK KPI AND NATIVE
AMERICANS COLLECTIVELY MAKING UP
THE REMAINING 39. OUR FINDINGS
FROM THIS REPORT EMPHASIZED THE
NEED FOR DEMOGRAPHIC REPORTING.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAS SAID THAT
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE MOST
STUBBORN STATES IN THE WORLD'S
MOST DIVERSE DEMOCRACY. BUT HOW
CAN WE KNOW IF OUR GOVERNMENT IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF THAT DIVERSITY
WITHOUT REPORT TO EVALUATE OUR
PROGRESS AS WE 72 ONLY REQUIRES
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION ANNUALLY
REPORT THE INFORMATION THAT IS
ALREADY BEING COLLECTED ON
APPOINTEES, WHICH MEANS THAT
THIS SIMPLE BUT EFFECTIVE BILL
WOULD COME AT NEARLY NO COST TO
THE ADMINISTRATION. OR CALL TO
ACTION REMAINS WE NEED IN HOUSE
REPORTING BY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO HIGHLIGHT WORK, GAPS
AND REPRESENTATION EXISTS BUT
REQUIRING ANNUAL REPORTING
STARTING IN 2027. THIS BILL
WOULD ESTABLISH A LEGACY OF
TRANSPARENCY FOR FUTURE
ADMINISTRATIONS AND WHAT
ADVANCED CALIFORNIA'S GOALS OF
HAVING A GOVERNMENT THAT IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE PEOPLE OF
OUR STATE. FOR THESE REASONS. WE
ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR OF SB 72
AND ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MR MORALES, UH, THAT WILL
MOVE, EDDIE. WHAT DO WE DO?
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY.
PLEASE COME UP. SEEING NONE. IS
THERE ANY WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION? ALSO SEEING THAT
WILL MOVE THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
THE MEMBER, SENATOR JONES. THANK
YOU, MR CHAIR. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. UH GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING. HAPPY NEW YEAR. THANK
YOU FOR POINTING OUT THAT THIS
IS OUR FOURTH ATTEMPT AT GETTING
THIS THROUGH. I'M LOOKING AT THE
TRACK RECORD. OF THE PREVIOUS
YEARS, AND YOU'VE DONE A REALLY
GOOD JOB. IT STARTED IN 2021
WITH 32 TO ON THE FLOOR 32 TO 0
IN THE SENATE, 62 TO 5 IN THE
ASSEMBLY. AND THEN IN 2022, YOU
WENT 31 TO 2. IN THE SENATE, 64
TO 9 IN THE ASSEMBLY. AND THEN
WORKED IT REALLY HARD. LAST
YEAR, YOU GOT IT TO 39 TO 0 IN
THE SENATE AND 78 TO 0 IN THE
ASSEMBLY. SO OBVIOUSLY YOU AND
YOUR TEAM AND THE ADVOCATES HAVE
DONE A GREAT JOB. UM BUILDING
OVERWHELMING SUPPORT FOR THIS
IDEA THIS CONCEPT IN THIS BILL,
UM I WOULD SAY, YOU KNOW, THE
FOURTH TIME'S THE CHARM. WHY
DON'T WE DO A VETO OVERRIDE AND
GET THIS PUT INTO LAW? WELL THAT
IS NOT A DECISION FOR ME TO MAKE
, BUT THIS IS A BILL THAT HAS
SIGNIFICANT BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
SO WE'RE JUST FORGET THAT POINT
TO IT IS SIGNIFICANT. BIPARTISAN
WAS SIGNIFICANT. VERY VERY
SIGNIFICANT PART IS YES. VERY
BIPARTISAN. WELL I THINK THAT
SOME OF US WOULD BE OPEN TO THAT
CONCEPT AND THAT IDEA IF YOU
WISH TO PURSUE IT. UM PLEASE LET
US KNOW. THANK YOU ENCOURAGE YOU
TO DO SO ACTUALLY. A LITTLE BIT
STRONGER THAN JUST SUPPORTING IT
WERE ENCOURAGING IT. THANK YOU.
I CAN'T SPEAK FOR EVERYBODY
ELSE. I'M ENCOURAGING. THANK
YOU, MR CHAIR. YOU KNOW, THIS IS
A SUPERB BILL, ACTUALLY. I
REALLY THINK IT SHOULD GO
FURTHER. BECAUSE THE DATA THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO GET A MAY NOT
NECESSARILY GIVE US THE
INFORMATION THAT WE REALLY NEED
IN ORDER TO FIX THE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE PROBABLY GOING TO FIND.
SOMETIMES WE ESTABLISHED
REQUIREMENTS FOR POSITIONS HERE
THAT THE GOVERNOR IS IN ENTITLED
TO FILL BY APPOINTMENT AND WE
PLACE REQUIREMENTS ON THE
INDIVIDUALS TO SERVE IN THOSE
POSITIONS THAT MAY POSE A
BARRIER. Tð SELECTION. AND SO AT
SOME POINT WE NEED TO EVALUATE
WHETHER THE REQUIREMENTS THAT WE
PUT ON SOME OF THESE POSITIONS
WHETHER IT'S AN ENGINEERING
DEGREE OR PHD AND WHATEVER ARE
ACTUALLY CREATING A BARRIER TO
DOING WHAT YOU INTEND TO DO WITH
THIS BILL, AND I'M SURE THERE
ARE OTHER EXAMPLES. SO MORE
DETAILED REPORTING IS PROBABLY
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
INCLUDE, AT A LATER DATE, SO THE
ADMINISTRATION MAY WANT TO BE
THINKING ABOUT THAT AS WELL. I
MEAN, OBVIOUSLY I'M GOING TO
VOTE. I THANK YOU. HELLO. I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THE POINT THAT
SENATOR JONES HAS MADE, UH THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE BEYOND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS LEGISLATION.
WE HAVE CO EQUAL BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT HERE WE ARE MAKING
THEM LESS COEQUAL BY DOING THIS
THIS IS THE FOURTH TIME THE
GOVERNOR IS GOING TO VETO IT
AGAIN. I MEAN, YOU KNOW HE'S
GOING TO VETO IT AGAIN. AND TO
CONTINUE. THIS IS LIKE LUCY
HOLDING THE FOOTBALL FOR CHARLIE
BROWN. AND YOU'RE CHARLIE BROWN.
AND IT MAKES NO SENSE WHATSOEVER
. UM AGAIN. THIS IS I DON'T I
DON'T VIEW THIS AS EARTH
SHATTERING LEGISLATION. IT'S
IMPORTANT BUT NOT EARTH
SHATTERING. BUT IT IS EARTH
SHATTERING TO ALLOW THE GOVERNOR
TO BE MORE THAN A CO EQUAL
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT IS A
VERY IMPORTANT POINT THAT GOES
BEYOND THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
LEGISLATION. AND I DON'T THINK
THAT THIS INSTITUTION SHOULD
ALLOW THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO
CONTINUE TO DICTATE TO IT WITH A
VIRTUAL UNANIMOUS APPROVAL OF A
PARTICULAR POLICY PROPOSAL AND
LET THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
OVERRIDE WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
OVERRIDING LEE HAS APPROVED.
OTHER THAN THAT. I DON'T HAVE AN
OPINION. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ARCHULETTA. THANK YOU. UH WE
HEARD THE FOURTH TIME MIGHT BE
THE CHARM, BUT WE'VE ALSO HEARD
THE PROGRESSION OF NUMBERS THAT
SEEMED TO BE INCREASING EVEN TO
THE 0.39 TO ZERO IN THE SENATE.
WELL GREAT NUMBERS. WHAT DO YOU
THINK HAS BEEN HAPPENING IS YOUR
IMPROVEMENT EACH YEAR? HAVE YOU
REACHED THE PINNACLE OF
FINALIZING THIS THING? WHAT HAS
BEEN THE PROBLEM? DO YOU THINK
OTHER THAN JUST THE GOVERNOR,
SAYING NO, BUT IF YOU'RE MAKING
PROGRESS, WE MIGHT BE JUST THERE
. I DO THINK THAT THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM IS THE GOVERNOR SAYING,
NO, I THINK THAT THERE IS
LEGISLATIVE INTEREST. UM, AND
SUPPORT FOR THIS. UH I THINK
WHAT WE HAVE DONE IT REGRETTABLY
, UNFORTUNATELY, RELIABLY, AND
UNFORTUNATELY TO SENATOR ROSS
POINT, UM, IS WE'VE ACTUALLY
NARROWED THE INFORMATION THAT WE
ARE COLLECTING. WE STARTED VERY
BIG, AND WE NARROWED IT WITH THE
HOPE THAT NARROWING IT. WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT WE YOU KNOW,
WOULD THEN BE APPROVED. UM ALL
MESSAGES HAVE BEEN SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS IN TERMS OF THE REASONS
FOR NOT SIGNING THIS, SO WE JUST
FEEL IT'S AN IMPORTANT BILL AND
I WANT TO STRESS TO THAT. IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE THERE'S
BEEN PAST REPORTS INDEPENDENT
REPORTS THAT HAVE BEEN DONE. FOR
EXAMPLE, U C L A DID ONE IN 2022
THAT ALSO SHOWED THAT SOME OF
THESE APPOINTMENTS. THE MAJORITY
75% OF THESE APPOINTMENTS COME
FROM THREE DIFFERENT AREAS IN
THE STATE. WE HAVE 58 DIFFERENT
COUNTIES, 480 PLUS CITIES. AND
SO WHAT WE'RE REALLY ALSO TRYING
TO GET IS REALLY ENSURING THAT
WE SEE THAT INFORMATION. UM AND
THAT FOLKS YOU KNOW, FROM
DIFFERENT PARTS OF OUR STATE ARE
ABLE TO WEIGH IN ON THESE REALLY
IMPORTANT BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
. SO IT IS, UM, WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS LEGISLATIVE APPETITE.
THAT IS EVIDENCED BY THE
INCREASING NUMBER OF VOTES IT
HAS. IT'S REALLY A MATTER OF HOW
WE CAN GET IT AND I WANT TO BE
VERY, VERY, VERY CLEAR THAT WE
ARE VERY OPEN TO WORKING WITH
OUR GOVERNOR AND THE OFFICE
RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD, BUT WE THINK IT'S AN
ISSUE. THAT'S UH, AS AS HAS BEEN
SAID. IT'S THIS ISN'T GOING TO
BE. YOU KNOW THE WORLD IS NOT
GOING TO CHANGE, BUT I DO THINK
THAT THE WORLD IN OUR STATE CAN
BE IMPROVED BY HAVING MORE
DIVERSE VOICES ON THESE 480
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS. AND WITH
THAT ON WOOD. SO ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM?
DO WE HAVE EMOTION? I THINK
ARCHER LENIN MADE THE MOST HE
ALWAYS DOES SO MOTION MOTION
MEET BY SENATOR ARCHULETTA. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THROUGH THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. DODD. I
WILK WILK ALVARADO KILL RADICAL.
I ARCHULETTA ARCHILA TÔI. ASHBY
ASHBY BY BRADFORD BRADFORD I
GLASER JONES JONES. I WIN. WHEN
I NILO HØI PADILLA QUARANTINE Ó
QUARANTINE. OI ROTH ROTH, I,
RUBIO RUBIO. I SEE ARDO CR D¯ÚI.
13 BECAUSE 13 VOTES THAT. WE'RE
GOING TO PUT THAT ON CALL.
APPRECIATE ALL THE MEMBERS,
ETCETERA. I DIDN'T EVEN ASK YOU
IF YOU WANTED TO CLOSE VOTE WAS
A GREAT CLOTHES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. UM
THANK YOU ALL. FOR THIS BOY
WE'RE GONNA DO WE'RE GONNA DO
WE'RE GONNA GO AROUND. I JUST
WANT TO THANK THOSE MEMBERS THAT
MADE IT FOR BOTH THOSE VOTES.
YOU CAN FEEL FREE TO LEAVE OR
STAY WHATEVER YOU WANT. I WANT
TO LET THE. DO. I KNOW. I TOLD
HIM WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT. SO
THOSE MEMBERS THAT ARE IN THEIR
OFFICE? I'M HOLDING THIS CALL
OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES AND I'M
CLOSING IT DOWN. SO CAN WE LIFT
THE CALL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. POLICE CONCERNED
ITEMS. THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. BRADFORD BRADFORD. I
GLASER. TO RUBIO. RIGHT NOW. I
SEE ARTO HØI. OKAY. 13 0. LEAVE
IT OPEN TO LEAVE THAT OPEN FIVE
MINUTES AND NOW WE'LL MOVE TO
FINAL ITEM NUMBER TWO SB 782 WE
HAVE ANYBODY NEW HERE? NO, OKAY.
SELLING REFUGE, SENATOR GLAZER
AND SENATOR PADILLA. WE NEED
YOU. IN ROOM 1200.
OPEN THE ROLE THAT CONSENT
PLEASE ABSENT MEMBERS. GLASER
GLASER, I PADILLA PADILLA. I 15
0. OKAY AND WE'RE GOING TO GO
NOW TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO.
WHAT'S THAT? WHAT WAS THE SCORE?
15 TO 0. THAT BILL PASSES THAT
BILL IS OUT. WILL NOW MOVE TO
OUR ONLY OTHER BILL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO. SB 782 SECRETARY OF
POLICE CALL THE ROLL MOTION IS
DUE PASS TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
ABSENT MEMBERS, GLASER. THERE
WAS I. GLASER I PADILLA TÔI 15 0
. IT'S OUT. 15 VOTES 15 0. THAT
BILL IS OUT, UM, SEPARATE. THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION IS NOW ADJOURNED